تحذير جديد وواقعي من
وزير الأمن الداخلي، نحن
بالتأكيد في بيئة شديدة التهديد
ونحن نمضي
بيقظة. تعليقات أليخاندرو ماي أوريس لشبكة
CNN تعكس تعليقات مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
كريستوفر راي الذي أخبر أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ أن
بيئة التهديد الحالية داخل
الولايات المتحدة هي  مختلف الآن عن
الفترات التي يقول فيها عندما ظهرت التهديدات الفردية
هنا وهناك، لم أر مطلقًا
وقتًا تكون فيه جميع التهديدات أو الكثير
من التهديدات مرتفعة في
نفس الوقت تمامًا، وهذا ما يجعل
هذه البيئة التي نحن فيها  الآن
محفوف بالمخاطر، هل يمكنك القول أن هناك
العديد من الأضواء الحمراء الوامضة هناك
أرى أضواء وامضة في كل مكان أتجه إليه،
قال راي إن مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي يعمل على
مدار الساعة لعرقلة الهجمات المحتملة
من قبل الأشخاص الذين يستلهمون
هجمات حماس الإرهابية على إسرائيل في
7 أكتوبر منذ ذلك الحين  في ذلك اليوم، تحدث راي كثيرًا
عن زيادة التهديدات داخل
حدود أمريكا المتعلقة بحرب
حماس على إسرائيل، ما هو المختلف فيما
يحدث الآن، يتحدث المخرج راي
عن هذا، لقد أصبح تيار التهديد
نوعًا من الشلال الذي
ترى فيه التهديدات تأتي  من
المنظمات الإرهابية الأجنبية داعش والقاعدة
أه المتطرفين العنيفين المحليين
هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين يتابعون
الدعاية القادمة من الخارج والذين
يمكن أن يكونوا مهاجمين لون وولف يقول الخبراء إن
التدفق المستمر للصور المتلفزة
ليوم 7 أكتوبر وحرب إسرائيل مع حماس
أدى إلى  طوفان من الدعاية من
الجماعات الإرهابية والمتطرفين من جميع
الأطراف، دعاية ومعلومات مضللة في كثير من الأحيان،
والتي قد يكون من
المستحيل تقريبًا تصفيتها، فهي موجودة على
لوحات الرسائل، موجودة في غرف الدردشة،
موجودة في مجموعات خاصة، موجودة
في مجموعات كبيرة، وارتفاع حاد في
معاداة السامية و  كانت التهديدات والهجمات المعادية للإسلام
كبيرة بدءًا من
إصابة ثلاثة
طلاب جامعيين فلسطينيين في فيرمونت وحتى
اتهام طالب بجامعة كورنيل بالتهديد
بقتل الطلاب اليهود. والخطر
الأكبر هو أن الجاني الوحيد
الذي قد يكون معزولًا قد يتم نبذه
ومن يقرأ هذه الرسائل.
وأقول إن بإمكاني الخروج والقيام بشيء
يقول المحللون إن الصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني المستمر
حتى قبل
السابع من أكتوبر كان في كثير من الأحيان نقطة اتصال
للكراهية في الولايات المتحدة. وما ترونه هو
أفراد يأخذون
التبرير الذي كانوا يبحثون
عنه  واستخدامه للقيام بالعنف،
هؤلاء هم الأفراد الذين أرادوا منذ فترة طويلة
ارتكاب أعمال عنف، كما تعلمون، وهم ممتلئون منذ فترة طويلة بتلك
الكراهية لليهود
والمسلمين من ذوي IND الذين ليسوا
في مجموعتهم في المهمة الصعبة المتمثلة في
محاولة حماية اليهود.
يقول وزير الأمن الداخلي ميكس إن الوكالات الحكومية الأمريكية قد
أصدرت للتو توجيهات جديدة تمامًا
للمؤسسات الدينية مع
اقتراحات محددة تتراوح بين بناء
سياج وتركيب كاميرات أمنية
في أماكن العبادة إلى تشجيع
الزعماء الدينيين على تطوير
علاقاتهم الخاصة مع القانون  إنفاذ بريان
تود سي إن إن واشنطن